the next award is a category which
combines both art and science special
visual effects be presented by the most
talented robert downey jr. at Jude Law
we are honored to single out those
Wizards of technological mastery who
have helped create the most spectacular
films the person whose idea of a good
time is muttering to themselves about
technical adjustments while you're
suspended upside down from a rig in
front of a green screen for six hours
relax their tireless work and
collaborate I who comes up to you when
you're about to take a leak and says I'm
sorry can I just put 60 tracking dots on
your face first
that type guy stop it right I'm not here
to be a part of your game so you get you
know people coming up to the after party
and saying how witty you are and how
charming you are or both shut up it's
their moment you know if it wasn't for
them your closest association with a
superhero would have been in 2001 when
you got busted in a cheap hotel with a
woman dressed as Batgirl
okay first of all that cheap hotel room
costs $1,250 a night with the corporate
discount secondly was mm not 2001 and
most importantly she was dressed as
Wonder Woman and that attention to
detail is what has won the respect of
all the Academy voters for these fine
men and women the nominees for
achievement in visual effects are Alice
in Wonderland Ken Ralston David Shaw
Carrie Villegas and Shawn Phillips Harry
Potter and the Deathly Hallows Part 1
timber John Richardson Christian man's
and Nicholas are tardy hereafter Michael
Owen's Brian grill Stefan Bryan ski and
Joe Farrell inception Paul Franklin
Chris corbelled Andrew Lockley and Peter
bear Iron Man 2 Yannick sirs
Ben snow Jed right and Daniels suit
and the Oscar goes to Inception poor
Franklin risk of old Andrew lock the
impede Abed
this is the first Academy Award for Paul
Franklin Chris Korbel Andrew Lockley and
Peter Babb
well um it feels like that top is still
spinning but I don't really care anymore
thank you very much Chris Emma Warner
Brothers
thank you to my producers Matt Plummer
and Mike chambers thank you to the
brilliant visual effects team at double
negative back in London and to my
amazing wife and our wonderful kids my
mum and dad back in Cheshire and to the
Academy for this all right I just want
to share this with my amazing special
effects teams in Los Angeles Canada
France Morocco and my great crew in the
UK and also to their families for their
support especially my wife Lynne and the
kids great thank you